sur en paix tu envoies de l'infini 13 6
me il est mort
il faut faire savoir que la drogue ne
sera plus toléré
votre attention washington veut qu'on
fasse le plus gros coup de filet de
toute l'histoire des douanes pablo
escobar ils sont adroits roberto al
qaïda
il est responsable de 80% de la drogue
dans ces pénibles promets moi que c'est
la dernière fois on va changer les
équipes masure tué avec un brio sans
regret c'était plat je les connais bien
tu dois jouer avec eux qui doit boire
avec eux tu dois faire tout ce qu'il
faut
lorsqu'on présente votre future épouse
moi aussi une fois une fiancée là
combien de missions à son actif
ok mais c'est la meilleure tu as fais
pas pour moi
gecina prend ainsi un mot de travers
c'est parti un faux pas
dans mon métier rien de bon ne se fait
sans un minimum de confiance
sans ça pas de loyauté et quand il n'ya
pas de loyauté
ça ne se termine jamais bien
bon résumé de crouch
peter
m
la rega
mike smith arkansas
l'attaquant de lorient